hi lad bible i'm margot robbie i'm
fender i'm donald glover i'm phoebe ryan
reynolds here and i'm going to be
playing a little thing called snack wars
the snake what the snack war snack war
snack wars snack wars not rules for lead
bible
let's do it
[Music]
bring on the snacks
oh
gnomes oh
spicy oh my god that's disgusting they
say never smell it never smell
oh
yes oh
this is from a place called greg's which
i have to assume is is local are you
sure it's not plastic it's rather hard
what is this
it looks like a
i don't know
i don't know what this is you can call
that like a a shield's dummy because
it's what what you give your kid a show
this is a sausage roll sausage roll wins
immediately this is a greg's sausage
roll this is the is it
i haven't tried this
[Music]
oh that's pretty edible it's nice and
warm
oh wow as always gotta be covered in it
i know what sausage roll tastes like
lads this wins i used to go to grace
every day when i was when i was at
secondary school there was one outside
my bus stop i also want to someone
stealing a sandwich from greg's and when
i say the guy sprinted down the road and
the people in groves were like he took a
sandwich and we're running after him
sandwich was like 95p my end our keynote
cleaner
clearly i don't want your end
not after last but you can't beat that
delicious delightful pretty good
amazing am i allowed to eat the whole
thing this wins come on states bring on
the sausage roll
and uh
chin chin
[Music]
finesse mmm i do love a hobnob
[Music]
oh how where what is that jellied eels
that's like i thought that was only
inflate oliver twist and stuff that they
ate
what
it's from
i'm still going to eat it though
bush tucker trail yeah let's do it and a
pork pie i mean this is like this is
just no contest is it no one eats that
no one i've only been up for like half
an hour
it's literally it is jellied
oh mate
oh
not now
let's lift that
just cash back that oh
oh my god
[Applause]
that is
why jelly who came up with that as
disgusting
there we go
oh
twiglets
i don't know what this is you can tell
it's local
it smells like cardboard
oh
oh
that's got a kick to it they're pretty
interesting actually
they kind of have a
a burnt taste to them
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go with these you
do draw actually can i change my answer
i'm gonna change my answer
sorry america i think it's twiglets um
i just
i have to be honest you know i just kept
wanting more twiglets
oh
this is
salt licorice candy licorice and these
are like greasy gummies
this is like from my
from my childhood
it's a very it's very it's a
salt licorice
is is very very popular
because we're weird
i'm very excited to see this
holy [ __ ]
sorry welcome
you people are crazy this is how we
treat ourselves that actually burns my
tongue
it tastes like a mouthful of seawater it
tastes like you'd made a mistake you
know what i mean when you fell into the
water
i can't believe you give that to
children
all righty go for it what would you like
go for the there's one okay
that's delicious
it's quite good
all the way i don't um like
candy in general but i if i'm
if i'm going to have some candy i think
it's going to be
feeling good
of course salt licorice in in any form
is it still in your teeth yeah yeah
is it going to spit out i'm rubbing this
bit but i'm definitely going to use my
cloth
that is insanity
no you're talking i look up at the oil
spectrum pen
well i'm not too sure about that i'm not
too sure but i am comparing it with the
red stripe
there's something really lovely about it
isn't there too it's just you know you
have one and it kind of quenches your
thirst you have two and the bodies start
to relax you have tree you start limbo
you have four
and you start to snore
that has to be the winner
[Music]
i'm not really that much of a fan of
cheese
let's definitely skip that one
i always wonder who was the first person
that went yeah i'll just try that a bit
of moldy cheese who was the first person
that thought that was all right
you
know oh
that's all right we got some warheads
and we got some swizzles love hearts
toxic waste hazardously sour candy i
know that's the one that makes your eyes
water and love hearts which is just you
know little love hearts on the tongue
all right
it's a nice watermelon program survive
the sour
savor the sweet oh so i gotta get
through a top layer of some [ __ ] in
order to get to the good stuff inside
and that describes america to a t
oh my god i hate that that's too bad
now i'm past it now once you get past
the harshness
oh
ain't worth getting to the suite man i
don't work that hard
i love hearts this one says will you
oh
oh
it says nothing it's actually is that
bad luck it's a crying sad face
in a love heart
i thought you were supposed to have nice
messages
share the love and i get a crying sad
face that's good
yeah those are nice cute um not sure but
what is it like dusty sweets it's like
it feels like a dusty sweet but nice
my winner
is probably actually gonna be the toxic
waste it set me off a little bit but
the aftertaste was really nice and
watermelon so i think if you can get
past that
toxic waste wind
what the hell is going on
what is that black pudding is basically
blood
[Music]
okay all right i'll take these
you can take those what is this that's
about to run straight through your ass
you think so yeah i know something
tim tams
i'm not eating no time
damn tiffany
try to tempt him
so good okay i'm gonna try the tim tam
go ahead
yeah you look like you just ate that
person that came over your house and
brought the potato salad you trying to
be nice
tastes like a grandma snack
that's not that's not how you eat the
oreo
okay
jesus christ what are you thirteen you
put the damn he's supposed to lick all
the white stuff out no okay that just
now wait a minute tiffany put it this
kid's watching this put the damn cookie
in your mouth this is how you're
supposed to eat the oreos all right okay
take a bite
that bad i'm not gonna do this okay
that's too much chocolate
it doesn't even come close same time the
fashion period what do you like better
the tim tam or the orange oreos that's
why i just gave you the one for being
bowling i'm gonna say the white house is
better too yeah come on
and that was snack walls for lab bible
what a journey holiday guys
what i love about doing interviews with
lad bible is um
the diabetes
jelly tots right yeah it's like kids how
would you say that
in a lilting english accent jelly tots
jelly tops
i love how suddenly you said it perfect
tell me